la première élection municipale le débat
[Musique]
bonsoir comment soit aussi merci d'être
des nôtres pour ce nouveau débat
consacré donc aux élections municipales
et communautaires gros plans donc sur la
ville dugourd morgue une ville connue
chez fréquenté pour sa richesse
verdoyante nous y reviendrons dans
quelques minutes ils sont 7 7 à se
partager donc le fauteuil de maire sept
candidats dans ce studio alone important
messieurs pour nous de vous donner la
parole mais donner la parole aura quand
même un sens c'est à dire messieurs
il serait intéressant qu'on se respecte
et serait intéressant que l'on s'écoute
il serait surtout intéressant que l'on
pense aussi aux auditeurs et surtout aux
internautes qui nous écoutent et qui
vont nous regarder histoire de ne pas
avoir de cacophonie dans ce studio donc
je pense que la reine elle est bien
comprise elle sera bien sûr respecter
par vous tous ici est à mes côtés donc
pour animer ce débat qui nous conduira
jusqu'à jusqu'aux environs de 19 heures
mais ressent car au jugement soit un bon
soir pédron soir à toutes et à tous
donc place maintenant pour la
présentation des candidats viennent me
bertrand
alors nous commençons par gilbert
couturier qui est âgé de 58 ans employée
il est maire sortant il s'allie staal au
soutien du mime
il est vice-président de cap nord et les
conseiller territorial à l'assemblée de
martinique il y a également autour de
cette table paul saint-yves crocherie
âgé de 77 ans fonctionnaire retraité à
la tête de la liste construisant pour
mieux vivre au gros morne et puis
troisième candidat aussi le présent ce
soir monsieur christian mary calixte âgé
de 58 ans chef d'entreprise il est à la
tête de la liste gros-morne 2020 et ben
voilà il n'a pas d'étiquette me
semble-t-il christian mary calixte vous
faites la suite des présentations grogne
est avec nous également ce soit vous
avez 62e annuel granier vous êtes gérant
de société bien connue d'ailleurs sur la
scène médiatique sur martinique puisque
vous êtes propriétaire d opter vais
conseiller municipal d'opposition vous
était également tête de liste
le gros mot comme ça vous avez appelé la
sicile aux gaullistes et vous avez bien
sûr l'investiture du ppm j'étais conseil
municipal de l'opposition 2008
très bien merci pour la précision jugnet
milthon et
avec nous également alors c'est vous le
plus je vous avais 49 ans 1 c'est bien
cela très bien vous êtes entrepreneur de
transport vous étiez encore récemment
maire adjoint vous avez démissionné il
ya de cela quelques mois pour devenir
opposants au maire et conduire la liste
gros mans ne vivra merci à vous d'être
là bertrand pierre louis est avec nous
également nous est sans existe sans
étiquette vous êtes tête de liste unie
pour le gros morne vous avait 57 ans
vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition divers gauche
vous êtes chef d'entreprise commerçants
et fuit pour finir raphaël vaugirard
vous êtes un habitué dans que de ces
élections
ce n'est pas la première fois
effectivement que vous présentez vous
avait 67 ans vous êtes cadres supérieurs
de collectivités donc de collectivités à
ccc la cité mc ça et surtout attachée
parlementaire de monsieur josé francisco
très bien vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition et membres que de cap nord
présentation la commune avec mme
bertrand car ' un gros morne en un clin
d'oeil aux normes compte au 1er janvier
2020 9860 neuf habitants contre 10250 en
la baisse de la population reste dans la
moyenne martiniquaise soit moins de 0 8%
gros morne et d'une des communes les
plus peuplées de la communauté
d'agglomération cap nord où la commune
est représentée par cinq délégués sur
les 54 membres du bureau communautaire
alors on va citer quelques principaux
quartiers de gros-morne hormis le celui
du bourg
on peut citer le quartier de la vierge
de terre de croix odilon ou encore tracé
manque d olive ou calvaire anciennement
le bourg était rattachée à la paroisse
de trinité avant que l'église soit
consolidée puis érigée en paroisse 1743
la commune de gros-morne elle même a été
créée en 1837 un territoire qui est en
haut lieu historique de l'économie
agricole avec une bonne part de
diversification vers les cultures
vivrières et maraîchères depuis au moins
le début du 20e siècle survivance de
cette diversification lusine de neil
fondé en 1908 pour transformer la nana
qui existent encore donc et qui produit
les jus de fruits et les confitures sous
la marque royal sans oublier évidemment
si la distillerie habitations
saint-etienne qui se trouve donc dans la
commune de gros morne qui fait en
superficie 18 mille deux cents hectares
avec une localisation enclavées elle est
l'une de nos sept communes sans littoral
le gros morne est entouré par saint
joseph trinité robert les habitantes des
habitants du gros-morne sont appelés
gros mornais et gros mornais une commune
où on l'avait dit il fait très bon vivre
une commune chatoyantes d'ailleurs pour
sa verdure
le tirage au sort vous a désigné
monsieur julien mille temps pour la 1er
la question d'aller voir ce n'est pas un
piège
ce n'est pas un quiz non plus mais
l'intéressant quand même pour nous le
savoir
intéressant également pour les auditeurs
qui nous écoutent également pour les
internautes aussi de savoir si vous
connaissez la date de la fête patronale
de votre commune au lieu d'être ne fait
pas tous les deux tribunes en masse le
14 juillet qu'ils ont que le fond au
moment mais nous sommes qu'on avait
déplacé et pourquoi êtes vous semble
parce que vous étiez parce que vous
étiez encore aux affaires dont vous
auriez dû connaître précisément que cite
cette date là où elle n'est pas sûre je
ne suis pas sûr 14 juillet oui bon à
loki autour de cette table connaît la
date de la fête patronale de sa commune
est ce piège
messieurs pardon je rectifie pas
rectifié ajouté parce que pour tout le
monde nous avait donné le long de la lys
qui les soutient enfin ils sont soutenus
et moi je suis investie par le ppm mais
si on l'a dit on l'a dit mais je les
pense ici on l'a dit on l'a dit
alors concernant les précédents l'adapt
ben comme vous l'avez dit j'ai 62 ans
j'ai toujours connu la fête patronale du
goût monde durant tout le mois de
juillet même avec un cinquième dimanche
quand ça tombe bien 4 juillet donc
c'était ça que je connaissais et les
courses de chevaux et de mulets démarré
juste devant chez moi à l'époque alors
la fête patronale du gros mots ça sera
cette année le 15 juin
je pense le contrôle de l'actuel maire
et l'important quand on se présente dans
une élection comme celle ci ne bien
connaître l'histoire de sa commune
messieurs absolument et encore il faut
connaître l'histoire de jésus même de
son pays parce que la commune n'est pas
indépendant elle n'est pas indépendante
du pays
donc le gone s'éteint c'est une commune
qui présente ses 5425 étant ils n'ont
pas 18001 nous sommes le deuxième
territoire et le lamentin qui fait 6300
quelques hectares le goût mona est il
toujours un haut lieu historique au lieu
de 2,2 de souffrance pour les esclaves
alors très souvent rien dit jean qui
s'enorgueillissent de ce que le google a
été capitale en 1790 - non parce qu'en
dix ans l indice nous étions dans un
système esclavagiste l'énigme nos aïeux
étaient est sous la férule sauce ou les
faire alors donc je ne m'ennuie pas
d'une d'une capitale esclavagiste dans
compte ce que je peux dire c'est que le
monde c'est une commune qui a produit
beaucoup de grands esprits de grands
artistes d'aider des enfants de valeur
et qui nous représente au plan
international celui qui allie max
morinière
nous sommes partis et d'autres encore le
fait d'être honneur qui selon les
informations que son revenu monsieur
gilles béhat couturier qui est près de
moi qui aurait perdu de sa superbe elle
serait tombée en désuétude
vous êtes le maire actuel qu'est ce que
vous avez à dire par rapport à cela
alors lorsque j'ai bonjour à tous et
reçoit tous ceux et celles qui nous
écoutent et qui n'ont rien dit lorsqu'on
parle d'une la fête d'une commune
fêtée à d'aussi à la dette de sa sainte
patronne si traditionnellement le 14
juillet et affecté mais la sainte
patronne donc la recette patoine delà de
la ville du monde c'est la dame de la
visitation
eh bien ça se passe le 30 mai je crois
que chacun peut décider de fait comme
bon lui semble mais la population a
quand même réclamé à ce que la fête soit
doux si à la fin à la fête de la sainte
patronne très bien ensuite votre
question aller sur escaut pas toujours
est il qu'ils laisseront winky qui ne
serait pas forcément aussi rehaussé
comme l'était auparavant
oui mais au fait c'est peu de moyens et
les fêtes patronales faisait je dirais à
la fête patronale c'était le moment où
toutes les associations toutes les
forces vives se réunissaient et s'il y
avait deux vitrines pour monter ce
qu'ils avaient fait pendant ce que font
les associations ce que fait les
artistes les commerçants tout le monde
se rencontrer mais il faut aussi dire
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui devant une
crise financière
rares sont les collectivités qui ont
envie de pouvoir s'investir
financièrement parce qu'on sait ce que
ça coûte quand il faut mettre en place
une fête patronale où il faut mettre la
sécurité puisque de plus en plus les
services de l'état vous exige de la
sécurité et quand on sent que quand on
sait que c'est minimum 20 à 40
je vais dire dix vigiles mais c'est pas
ce thème l'un qui sur les agents de
sécurité la sécurité et bien ça fait un
coup ça fait un coup et si nous avions
des entreprises bien implantées dans la
commune pouvant participer peut-être que
ça aurait donné mais seuls desnel hse le
idée admise piéjos ou d'autres petites
associations ou d'autres petites
entreprises qui sont là c'est pas cette
reprise la avait que six au bois les
arts look son nom m'échappe bien tous
les cas d absurde et des entreprises qui
ont envie d'y participer mais au coût de
cette fête
je pense que au fait on est en mesure de
pouvoir aller engager interne de
dépenser lorsqu'on a les moyens pour te
connais la section financière de la
ville où l'équipe municipale en place
la première des choses très bien dit
important c'était d'analysé et de voir
en fait ce qu'on pouvait mettre en place
à partir de quoi pouvait faire quoi vous
pouvez investir sur quoi on pouvait nous
aurons donc un avenir tout au long de
cette émission que sion fink cantonales
parce qu'on fait avant de faire la fête
patronale et pour tenir compte de la
situation sociale de la population nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir tout au
tout au long de cette recette de cette
soirée elle nous avait compris quand
même qu'il était important effectivement
le revenu cette question puisque une
fête patronale comme d'habitude à a pour
origine de rassembler l'ensemble des
habitants le que de la localité
dans un instant messieurs nous allons
aborder le premier thème de notre débat
de ce soir celui de l'agriculture mais
juste avant je vous propose d'aller sur
les terres gros mornais et prendre le
pouls donc de la population nous avons
donné la parole aux habitants au travers
du micro de fabrice de frémont dans un
instant nous allons donc pouvoir écouter
donc les réactions donc des habitants
donc gros mornais sur leur pensée
comment ils voient leur commune et
comment donc ils sentent le bon vivre
aux gourmands laisse que nous pouvons
écouter beaucoup qui coûte y en a pas on
n'a pas pour l'instant cette possibilité
mais en tout cas selon les réactions que
nous avons eues il semblerait que
beaucoup de personnes soit désenchanté
certain nombre assez désabusé se serait
donc sans me semble-t-il
mauvais état d'esprit pour l'instant qui
n'eurent est donc dans cette cette
commune on a la possibilité d'entendre
maintenant donc les habitants en tout
cas quelques uns de la ville du gombo
les côtes quatre mois j'attends il ya du
tout leur slogan de sous les mers il n'y
a pas d'argent donc sans le nerf de la
guerre
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ils sont
henry lui ou en place et mais ça sera le
même train train habituel demandons
c'est au monde l'homme ont une évolution
dont on est dans cette dynamique là pour
pouvoir changer les choses et bien
j'attends la continuité de l'équipe
municipale
c'est de renouveler leur confiance ça
fait trente sans colle au gone est en
perte de vitesse pendant six ans il a
fait bouger les choses comme il pouvait
pas cette finance donc je pense que la
phase de maturité est arrivé et je pense
qu'il faut continuer non je n'attends
rien de spécial même poule est tout
petit a pas de bibliothèque à tanguer
parce que ce sont tous des montres sur
le même disque que j'ai plus mauvais
changement quand même ce qu'il faudrait
pour le grand chose nous avons même qui
nous aide beaucoup
passerelle a pris quand même quand on
parle je suis pas politicienne est déjà
dit que comme ça mais il prend une ville
endettée et qui le fait remonter à un
certain niveau il faut le reconnaître
quand même on est des gens sérieux et
puis une fois ci de là une fois que
l'ami contre qui je suppose va susciter
un certain nombre de réactions de votre
part autour de cette table les personnes
interrogées vous avez entendu sont
désenchantés d amuser démobilisés ce
serait le résultat de votre politique
pendant six années monsieur gilbert
couture et quoique lino mal que la
population ne soit pas satisfaite
puisque prenant au mot de temps nombre
d'années on a connu une situation
particulière
et la nouvelle municipalité que unités
gonese a eu la majorité en 2014 eh bien
c'était de pouvoir apparaître six et
financière fait un constat et voix au
fait quelles sont les priorités
mais lorsque vous êtes partis avec des
bâtiments publics
je parle des écoles dans un piteux état
écueil et l'éducation fait partie de nos
priorités
eh bien il faut aller investir je prends
l'école maternelle l'afficheur lorsqu'on
a pris une classe avec des petits de 2
ans qui devait s'ouvrir
eh bien c'était véritablement une
piscine d'eau qu'il fallait améliorer
lorsqu'on prend les infrastructures
toujours dans les écoles des quartiers
mêmes possibilités même situation
particulière et nous prenons au niveau
d'une mairie où une subvention avait été
donnée par une ancienne région de 600000
euros en 2009 et que peut être nous
prenons en 2014 les projets v8 ne passe
pas ficelé et bien il faut prendre le
temps de pouvoir mettre en place
lorsque vous prenez alors que ce
bâtiment devait être à l'ordre
à l'heure des habitants qui concerne
public de clients européens
eh bien nous constatons que la sécurité
l'accessibilité pour les casinos
certains handicaps n'étaient pas réunies
lorsque nous voyons dans l'état des
routes où il fallait ou et mettre en
place une situation des financières il
fallait vous constatez seul de recul dit
qu'ils étaient capables et à partir de
ce moment là nous avons fait le travail
nécessaire le parent automobile qui
était véritablement de 26 véhicules et
bien tous des véhicules chaque fois que
je joue pour le 5 août pour payer des
aspects un monsieur brisure y ait 100
millions et devant de monsieur couture
allez je vous propose d'en garder sous
le coude parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre location messieurs vous avez
entendu les réactions de ce mythe
micro-trottoir monsieur croc schrey
nous savons que vous qui est le plus
ancien est ce que vous avez connu le
gros mot comme ça avec des gens aussi
d'immobiliser absolument je dois dire
quelques mots puisque j'ai accompagné
d'hubert coudurier pour être mère d'hugo
monde mais si je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est que je suis vraiment déçu parce
qu'une fois gilbert couturier était
arrivé à la commune il a fait cavalier
seul
il a fait quasiment cavalier seul et moi
il m'a mis de côté tout de suite ses
adjoints la communauté soudée par trois
ou quatre personnes
j'ai toujours essayé de comprendre
comment ça marche et d'ailleurs est
jamais venu j'ai jamais plus le temps
d'aller un conseil municipal parce que
crête entendent des choses qui ne me
plaisait pas donc mais j'avais des
nouvelles
j'avais des gens qui me m'apporter ce
qui se passait pour venir pour moi
personnellement
gilbert couturier n'a rien fait pour la
commune du beau monde il n'a absolument
rien fait et il est là je peux lui
demander est-ce qu'il peut montrer où il
a planté un clou sous la commune d'ibn
clary un seul coup d'oeil en deux en
dehors en dehors de panneaux
publicitaires
on peut voir qui a fonctionné seulement
pour un mois on avait de l'argent dessus
l'argent des contribuables pour panneaux
publicitaires qui a coûté les yeux de la
tête et le bras baissés
ces panneaux publicitaires à fonctionner
seulement trois mois ok c'est ce que
vous retournez comment ce soit que vous
retenez non mais mais je n'ai rien vu
les jeux ont dit qu'il n'a pas d'argent
je vais de vous dire j'ai fait le tour
aujourd'hui j'ai pris mon temps de faire
le tour de toutes les quartiers de
gourbanguly très bien on va donner la
parole à monsieur gravier c'est juste
une réaction par rapport à cette
démobilisation actuelle que danse dans
votre ville je voudrais revenir sur
seconde disait sur la fête patronale
alors oui mais je sais pour répondre
aussi en partie aux personnes qui ont
encore fait le micro trottoir
il faut savoir que lorsque vous faites
une fête patronale aussi c'est une
entrée d'argent pour la commune parce
qu'il y a des gens qui viennent de
toutes parts pour pouvoir ne serait ce
que pour un dépistage les balles
fonctionne ya des restaurants qui
fonctionne et ça fait entrer de l'argent
dans la commune et ça permet aussi aux
ingrédients de pouvoir s'amuser un
certain moment donc je pense qu'il faut
pas mettre cette partie là de côté
concernant le concernant sur que ce que
je viens d'entendre
moi je peux comprendre je comprends
aisément
moi je passe dans les rues du monde jean
jeu par lettre les commerçants qu'est ce
que les commerçants 20 10 ils n'ont plus
de clients parce qu'on a un souci de
parking au monde
il ya des gens qui travaillent fort de
france ô qui des fois qu'ils travaillent
en mairie qui garent leur voiture
donc toute la journée les voitures sont
garées et les gens qui voudraient
peut-être s'arrêter point chez quelque
chose dans un courrier aux mots ils ne
peuvent pas le faire donc ça les
commerçants du gaumont disent qu'il
faudrait trouver une situation pour
changer ça engouement
donc je peux comprendre ce ras-le-bol
des deux sera fin des habitants comme
monnaie de ce que je viens d'entendre un
bertrand pierre louis on se tourne vers
vous quel regard vous vous posez sur les
six dernières années qui se sont
écoulées
est ce que vous considérez
qu'effectivement le travail de la
municipalité sortante n'a pas été de
sorte à enchanter finalement les
administrés oui si le pourcentage des
achats tu maîtrises et pourtant quand on
regarde ya six personnes interrogées il
ya plus de près de 4 sur sur six qui
sont pas très contents
donc je dirais que moi je ne je n'ai pas
à critiquer la fonctionnement ni lui ni
l'homme qu'il est gilbert youtube mais
pas en compte la gestion la gestion ne
va pas c'est pas cette gestionnaire qui
forme commune ne vous critiquez pas
l'homme mais vous critiquez leur la
gestion non géopolitique nous sommes
tous je connais tous les to les
messieurs qui sont ici présent je n'ai
pas de quelques particuliers à faire
l'objet des actuelles mais la gestion de
la commune qui de l'élévation qui fait
là j'ai pas seulement une équipe d'accès
tout comme moi je veux une équipe parce
que c'est bien pour ça j'ai par
l'adoption d'un conseil déjà les
composés de pilote le capitaine et d'une
équipe
donc s'il lui au moins il ne voyait pas
l'équipe devrait pouvoir réagit
aujourd'hui on se retrouve un que je
vais le dire du tout vous dire mieux
isolés parce que son équipe ne répond
pas aux attentes aux manquements qu'il
pourrait avoir donc que je serai prêt à
tendre la main c'est ça non parce que je
suis présent ici comme candidat ne s'est
pas portée de la main donc si je vous
dis aujourd'hui que quelqu'un qui arrive
avec une équipe solide
des experts en tous cas il ya des
experts recommandent à tous les domaines
à vous entendre au moins il a fait de
mauvais choix de ses coéquipiers de
c'est ce que vous avez entre mardi mais
ce sont ceux qui travaillent à la cape
et le capitaine est en charge de ces
équipes aussi j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
dire plusieurs fois au conseil municipal
monsieur lee mais ça n'a pas loupé des
fans cavignaux ses collègues il a beau
joe hill à nos cabinets c'est nous qui
faisons la couronne il faut débarquer
les jeux qui n'ont pas envie de
travailler parce que mon sort du travail
je m'arrange pas arrivé à l'heure vous
jugera aussi et chaque fois nous sommes
en manque de personnes pour tenu son
conseil municipal nokia - formant des
décisions farfelues et sur la table donc
aujourd'hui sur mécontentement généré
avec l'existant ça se comprend parce
qu'effectivement ça donne l'impression
et pas seulement les pressions on a
l'impression que c'est parce que cette
ville n'avance pas notamment pour le
soir le parking aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de concertation vraiment pour les
parkings c'est très bien si vous aviez
c'est le moment de jouer le combiné très
bourg est ensuite devenu bobo
là c'était un travail formidable
engouement mais n'est élevé fallu que
notre municipalité soit en concertation
avec ses conseils avec cette septième
pour nous permettre nous sommes le seul
chanteur tu vas pas il convient sans
gagner les goûts version ne peuvent je
peux mettre une plume arrêté pour
acheter un pain et je constatais cette
semaine alors qu'on est très attention
attention doit venir sur l'aménagement
du premier parc en aménageant bachelot
on a du temps donc il faut que les
autres puissent s'exprimer aussi
d'ailleurs
monsieur christian mary calixte on vous
pose la même question votre regard sur
cette mandature qui s'achève au gros
morne ont fait le bilan après le micro
trottoir on fait un peu le bilan est
donc allé quel est le vôtre quoi même en
bill haas et que effectivement si je
suis candidat aujourd'hui c'est parce
que j ai regardé monsieur candidat
monsieur coutumier candidat en 2014
c'est quelqu'un qui a fait beaucoup de
choses dans sa vie associative que je
connais mais je ne dis pas qu'il n'a
littéralement rien fait mais il n'a pas
fait ce que demande le gominé ce qu'il
avait promis
d'accord aujourd'hui le gone est
désespérée les goums rodez et les gones
sont désespérés sans espoir sans espoir
maintenant j'entends dire y'a pas
d'argent et que comme n'y a pas d'argent
va reconduire le maire
tout choix est un engagement judicieux
mon assise au moins 2 ou gonnet faire le
choix de jb rotulien 2020 tout choix est
un engagement vous êtes complice de vos
douleurs et vous désespoir si vous
réduisez bien coutumier mais je ne dis
pas que je suis un mauvais mais il a
fait ce qu'il pouvait avec l'équipage
qui pouvait il a souvent dit que j'avais
fait un exposé on prévoit lui la
exposants à l'enregistrement très bien
et que vous avez parlé de complices un
instant et deux de ses anciens complices
et monsieur jugnet multon puisque vous
avez fait partie de ce conseil municipal
justement vous avez quitté ce conseil
municipal en plein vol il ya de cela à
peine quelques mois vous
quelque part on peut dire vous êtes
aussi contam de la désespérance de la
désolation effectivement kof xi en fait
les habitants d'une partie des habitants
faille par oui alors au monde et par mon
départ est venue bon au départ ça alors
je veux revenir aussi sur la culture
puisque vous parle d'éjaculation n'a pas
de projet c'est vraiment une question
simple vous avez entendu le
micro-trottoir oui vous avez entendu la
désespérance vous avez entendu cette
désolation qui parle au gros morne
je vous demande simplement vous avez
fait partie de ce conseil municipal quel
est le bilan puisque vous avez fait
partie des actions si mise en place par
son conseil municipal
oui je suis là pour avec vous alors mon
bilan c'est bon vous avez vous avez mère
quand il décide quelque chose il décide
et puis le fait ses affaires de un
certain moment le mellah le maire ne
prend pas le temps d'écouter
quand vous lui parlez il n'ya pas vous
répondre c'est moi qui mets cemac abats
d'animaux a même si vous discutez avec
lui dans une veine une zac ça plusieurs
fois donc
moi je pense est le résultat de son
travail son travail jusqu'à ya pas être
nommément des changes avec lui 1 et
quand ils imposaient c'est le projet
bien couturier est un autocrate en
quelque sorte si vous voulez non pas si
vous voulez jouer pour moi qu'il faudra
attendre c'est ce que vous avez l'air de
décrire et oui moi je nomme je n'ai rien
imposé que si oui mais oui mais oui les
un autocrate
oui très bien s'exhaler assumait alors
que vous assumez les oui j'assume très
bien là travaillent avec lui je
travaille avec lui j'ai par la vision de
monsieur vaugirard sur sur ambiance et
surtout morne
alors je veux commencer par dire que je
ne venais pas contre quelqu'un ni dans
un affrontement de personnes dans ces
élections mais j'avais pour ma commune
pour défendre ma commune parce que tout
un an 6 ans tous les lieux qui
organisent la vie quotidienne de la
commune sont fermés l'église en 2015 le
stade en 2017 la cantine scolaire la
fait pas tourner à la bibliothèque
symbole d'accès à la culture pour nos
jeunes est fermée
la caisse des écoles a été mis en veille
bref c'est une destruction de tous ceux
qui organisent la vie dans la communion
c'est pourquoi le mouvement que j'ai
l'honneur d'animer s'appelle sos et
souhaite de santé c'est pour sauver la
commune et puis pour lui proposer un
autre avenir
et puis je veux dire aussi que le
meilleur coup mais des erreurs de
gestion des eaux de manacor avec mon
collègue bertrand père lui semble nous
qui sommes de l'opposition treize fois
n'ya pas de courant y'a pas le conseil
municipal
et puis d'autres pas en matière
d'association
le maire on dirait qu'il s'est ingénié à
asphyxier les associations et en
particulier le river sourdif au point
que au moment où ce que montent en
division d'honneur en régionale 1
excusez moi de le dire maintenant aucune
aide
un brin à l'association même pour
l'entraînement il un problème pour
s'entraîner sur un sou de saintes
c'est le groupe électrogène nous a
permis de
puisque les adhérents soit disant
chantier c'est le robert qui est bleu et
des sportifs en prêtant 1-1 l'estrade
alors écoutez pour moi le gaumont a
perdu 6 ans avec monsieur couturier mais
cela n'a pas été en mesure et quant à
cap nord n'en parlons même pas un look
et les 3è vice-président ont dit qu'il
n'a pas d'argent mais messieurs dames à
quatre noms en compte un centre de 2018
cap nau qui a un budget de 60 millions
présenté un excédent de gestion de 10
millions d'euros je suis même de la
commission des finances
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas de
dossier il n'y a pas de projet d'accord
au cap nau en appel n'a pas encore la
dynamique pour pour en tant que moteur
de projets mais les communes non plus
n'en n'ont pas le social comme seule
finale
je prie pouvoir un dossier du goum en
rien le maire n'est pas en mesure de
monter un projet et des projets
pourraient pour faire avancer sa commune
c'est pourquoi nous avons perdu six ans
en a perdu 6 ans dit ce soir monsieur
vaugirard
je me tourne vers vous monsieur gilbert
couturier puisque ce soit visiblement
vous cristalliser toutes les attentions
nous serait un autocrate vous êtes sourd
totalement sourd voir aveu main donc aux
projets des uns des autres
on a du mal à vous toucher vous régné en
maître sur l'avenue de combat mais de la
démocratie assure vous nous dire en
maître de la mutualisation
je crois que l'élu adjoint en charge de
l'électricité aux semaines que j'ai
donné mission qui dit ou fait ne peuvent
pas fait de papier des propositions vous
tombez de julien hamilton et bien ce
fameux candidat ce candidat qui avait
pour mission l'électrification et bien
va faire poser un poteau sans que je ne
sache sur un terrain privé
il ne voilà-t-il pas un samedi on
m'interpelle me dire voici un pylône
électrique a été déposé il a été dit que
vous allez faire couper les branches
après qu'on ait posé le poteau et quand
la lampe la lumière est émise
voilà on mettait pas de me dire
qu'aujourd'hui on veut méfiant d'élaguer
c'est la mairie qui doit envoyer quand
elle va l'envoyer
alors je découvre mais comme je suis pas
lâche je ne dis pas au fait je suis pas
au courant
donc je prends et j'en assume c'est ça
aussi la démocratie c'est ça vous fait
d'être autocrate accepter qu'on donne
une délégation et puis on peut pas venir
donc c'est un contre-temps voulais dire
c'est que si vous vous avez eu des
erreurs d'appréciation pour choisir vos
collaborateurs
mais ce militant a eu des erreurs
d'appréciation il a fallu maintenant
nous ne souhaitons pas faire moi je
crois que il ya un groupe unité gonesse
qui est arrivé avec des élus et chacun
voulait apporter mais simplement rentrer
dans la mission d'élu comprendre la
mission d'élu comprend quand on a une
délégation l'obligation de pouvoir
rencontre je suis à 4 nages en prison
compte à rebours président de monthieu
dans toutes les missions que j'ai acquis
ma qui m'a confié je suis à la septième
jeu rend compte au président marie
jeanne or plus à la prise de la
commission équipe type tu te fais tout
ça remonte à beaucoup plus haut john
être auto iv s'est donné la parole est
donnée démission est au tour quand j'ai
demandé au fait qu'à chaque six mois on
avait fait le bilan la population
pendant la mandature
et puis on n'est pas présent si cette
auto coteaux tout cas j'en assume
seulement je vais aussi revenir sur
l'idée au fait des dossiers de reprise à
terre cartes non alors ça c'est monsieur
vaugirard qui vous a fait cette critique
je trouve extraordinaire que des
dossiers qui a été peint des dossiers le
prêt de convergence de ces qui monte
avant que la commune n'ait pris une
délibération par le représentant de
monsieur monsieur quitté le 26 janvier
dans une présentation du projet en main
le dossier à la commission finances
commission finances devaient se réunir
le 19 février 2018
qui c'est qui prend et qui attaquent le
dossier celui qui est membre comme ceux
financés qui dit qui n'a jamais vu
d'aussi mais m'envoie un email le 14
février qui est un jour février et
mercredi des cendres et l'envoie mail
pour dire que voici un dossier que je
vais défendre
donnez moi les éléments pour que je
puisse défendre ce dossier mais surtout
si n'est pas envoyée par la bbc
ces personnels de cristiano jr tels que
ça non c'est le dossier cen dossier mais
oui pas de convergence qui arrive à cap
non mais c est menée par le monde qui
vous présentais monsieur montueux à une
vie lignon parce que pour pour ce second
représentant pour madame états unis us
c'est un projet pour la résilience qu'il
fallait faire vite
dont celui ci arrive mais quand il la
commission qu'est ce qu'il fit il dément
tribu les unités le dossier est ce vous
girard attend demain
et quand il fait ça les autres membres
de la commission mais tellement est cet
engouement n'est quel problème que j'ai
avec lui et il a dit qu'on n'a pas
développé le problème avec antoine où il
a travaillé contre le gros morne à cap
nord je sais qu'on voulait dire se
cherche et accusés chacun assume ensuite
on essaie de bien les gérer au mieux
outillés cependant quand tu pendant
l'été revient pas l'église effet omis le
stade est fermé qui a découvert le stade
qui a eu la gestion de la mairie pan de
2008 à 2009 et relevé alors attention du
service et vos familles vos sessions de
saint-didier votre pensée vous êtes en
ai compris les gens qui étaient en reste
comme abidjan pendant six ans si énorme
il amène le monde a travaillé sur le
dossier tout tient
et puis ils n'ont jamais présenté le
projet aujourd'hui des poules gr sont
arrivés son fils les préfinancements
continent s'affiner et bien ça à fond le
jeu comprend bien oui on ne fallait sans
aucun logo monde à bord d'une situation
financière mais aussi manager rien et
puis pouvoir préparer leur demande
aujourd'hui pour la prochaine mandature
nous passons à la mandature d'exécution
nous allons revenir mais c'est cool et
rit on va y revenir aux gagnants
merveilleux revenir au maire alexandre
jean lagarde le premier thème de ce soir
me suis arrêté des matériels de 910 vous
aurez l'occasion de vous
même si les occasions répandue le
premier thème pour ce soit développement
agricole la ville gourmande comme on le
sait est enclavé entre saint-joseph
trinité roubert communes rurales on l'a
dit mais peut-on penser je vais vous
donner la parole monsieur préférant
comme ça vous allez répondre en même
temps peut-on penser que l'économie de
la commune peu reposé uniquement que sur
le secteur agricole non pas du tout le
groupe en a beaucoup d'autres atouts
mais je veux quand même clarifier
quelque chose bon juste vous dire
monsieur gautier ne ridiculise et anouk
romaine à ce point là écoutez je suis
même la commission des finances
je suis convoqué en commission finances
y était avec eux le collègue et je vois
que le gaumont d'un projet de parler de
convergence de 26 millions en conseil
municipal en a jamais vu de dossier vu
des skis ce but de de l'avant projet de
la maison
et bien justement rêver c'est ça c'est
ça qui vous comprenez pourquoi dossier
qui a présenté à quatre morts mais était
ce jeudi
alors alors j'écris j'envoie un mail au
m me dit monsieur le maire j lo
participer tel jour en commission des
finances en douce et du monde pour vinci
non c'était 21 millions cette année par
grimpé à 26 ans j'ai dit comme je n'ai
pas vu la faisabilité de ce projet
pourriez vous me donner des éléments
pour que puisse intervenir pour ne pas
communiquer les mauvais cap nau alors
monsieur coutu et un tir passa comme si
j'avais dit qu'en langue mouche est le
même et c'est ridicule mais je
continuais à poney au moins alors à vous
y rendre
je vais agir autrement combien c'est
vous qu'il clique et pour les efforts de
domaine agricole cassoulet vert alors en
matière d'école
le groupe présente un potentiel
extraordinaire mais comme beaucoup de
communes agricole nous sommes confrontés
à un déficit d'exploitation bananière un
déficit d'exploitation ont donc moins on
a des usines confirmé les uns convient
de lusine saint-etienne et aidera qui
fait que la reconversion agricole et
difficiles au monde mais rien d'aider
des petits agriculteurs qui qui qui qui
tente de prendre le relais et c'est très
divisée alors ne sont pas suffisamment
comment une municipalité peut soutenir
ce secteur et aider justement
c'est dans ces professionnels alors en
matière d'agriculture la compétence
n'est pas non plus n'est ce pas
le président allemand il faut offrir des
dossiers il faut faire les deux sociétés
aux agriculteurs il faut que nous
invitons s'inscrivent dans le projet de
programmation agricole qui se fait
notamment à la chambre d'agriculture et
avant l'encadrement entièrment de désign
wanna go et c'était un pot qu'on puisse
redynamiser la culture mais nous avons
des petits agriculteurs qui sont
extrêmement actifs augmente sa vocation
avant tout alors vous plaît monsieur
marc calixte a beaucoup de temps de
parole de retard on va lui donner la
parole d'autant qu'il est utile et du
milieu agricole des exploitants la
nature donc
estimez-vous que ça l'agriculture la
production agricole se porte
suffisamment bien au gros morne et est
ce qu elle a surtout eu le bon soutien
de la municipalité ces temps derniers y
est ouais c'est un dernier il ya des
critères qui fonctionne au goût -
monsieur gilbert couturier a été
apparentée l'agriculteur à recevoir les
producteurs de la matinée qu'il était
présent et juste je crois qu'il a vu
quelque chose qu'il n'a jamais vue
ailleurs en martinique 1 la production
la diversification des navigateurs ces
mêmes agriculteurs et aussi ce n'est pas
vous non c'est mon frère d'accord c'est
son cousin c'est son cousin alors je
veux dire quelque chose injustice pour
l'histoire on dit dans l'histoire de
l'humanite de l'humanité mort sont les
pays qui ont connu une croissance
économique sans avec le job d'accord
mais moi je vais vous dis ce que j'ai
fait et vous dis ce que j'ai fait je
vous ne vous êtes aussi une histoire de
famille en or de vous être en mesure ce
soir de vous entendre comme ça on a une
des divergences de vue
un satan oui c'est moi qu'on se voie
rapide moi j'ai fait un audit les
indicateurs sont tous négatifs
écoutez bien un déclin démographique
passage obligé sous la barre des 10000
habitants une population vieillissante
la fermeture de tous les commerces
d'accord est aussi une pop et des
exploiteurs agricole s'envole à un
abandon du bout du bout un déclin des
assauts de la vie associative comme
disait monsieur sauf au titre du positif
on saute et un cadre de vie attractif
une amélioration des voies de
communication et monsieur couture est en
train de faire là vous élargissez on
était sûr oui oui mais je reviens juste
je reviens pour dire de la lisa sion du
secteur agricole la la la la
communication à dire les voies de
communication on parlait de
d'enclavement d'accord les arguments ne
sont pas entraver les agriculteurs même
s'ils font des dossiers il ya des
agriculteurs qui ont des dossiers et qui
ont des volontés de s'en sortir
et comme je dis ici à qatari qtel qui
fera par les gones exploitation
bananière mais est ce que ces
agriculteurs qui ont des projets est-ce
qu'ils ont été accompagnés par l'équipe
sortante sorte
est-ce que la la la la municipalité ont
fait on fait aussi le bilan là là là
vous allez dire je vous proposez vous
mais voilà parce qu'à votre sens
monsieur couturier son équipe ont ils
suffisamment soutenu le secteur agricole
récemment il a aidé beaucoup un
navigateur un jouet merci merci beaucoup
monsieur calixte monsieur marc calixte
pardon monsieur le procureur vous avez à
77 ans vous avez de l'expérience de
volume dans l'union d'expérience l'encré
alors quel avenir voyez-vous pour le
domaine agricole hambourg morne pour
vous dire
le manager kologo mal rien ne se passe
si nous n'avons pas des fonds or il n'y
a pas d'accompagnement il faut pas
oublier une chose de france et de
navarre et fermes agricoles ou les
petits agriculteurs se sont accompagnés
par les municipalités
pourquoi je le dis eh bien c'est gilbert
coûté yacco mieux placé pour le savoir
puisque idéal a cité m et la ctm qui
gère le feder le fonds européen de
développement pour les agriculteurs pour
les pêcheurs pour les entrepreneurs
donc il est à même de faire des deux
réunions à la municipalité un succès si
on vous parle pas de lui n'ont pas de
vous mais dans cette colonie vous
comment voyez vous l'avenir
c'est surtout ce qui nous intéresse ce
soit donc je vous invite que je pars
vous parlez si ça part un peu de vos
provient tout simplement mon projet même
analysis et qu il faut faire le
développer le gone il faut déjà un
marché par que le produit il faut
écouler leurs produits
il faut avoir un endroit pour écouler
son produit est accompagné puisque
actuellement
comment voulez-vous engouement n'est
peut aller à
le l'agriculture puisque il faut qu'ils
descendent soir à fort de france ou
ailleurs
autrement ils sont au bord de la route
augmente depuis le marché du groupe
depuis lé devant la mairie jusque à un
supermarché vous rencontrez des
marchands au bord du trottoir qui vont
au bout du rouleau
moi je dis c'est désolant c'est désolant
doc donc alors moi j'ai eu un vrai
projet c'est que c'est l'accompagnement
tant qu'il n'y a pas d'accompagnement
donc tout ce que nous faisons
actuellement je vis et tout va vite pas
que nous avons internet nous avons tous
on peut accompagner des gens mettre des
équipes sur place pour accompagner les
gens bertrand pierre louis oui votre
analyse sur cet aspect je suis
agriculture s'est repris alors je sens
la journée à ranger sur le territoire du
gros morne
il ya aussi des comment dirais-je pas
mal de projets d'agritourisme aussi un
certain disent que ça peut être un
avenir pour la commune voilà le genre
parce que oui mais ça sur la table et
nous allons venir
jal en venir parce qu'effectivement je
suis issu d'une famille harry caul aussi
parce que mon père était jean
d'exportations agricoles notamment des
bananeraies sur plusieurs plus
expression agricole de banane sur leur
monde et vous savez que le t1 sont
excessivement pollué par le chlordécone
augmente donc il faut changer et penser
à nos petites de la culture au monde une
commune je conçois que se mettre dans la
tête une commune n'a pas vocation à
créer des emplois ou à créer de
l'activité économique
elle doit être porteur de projet
économique pour faciliter l'implantation
de deux porteurs de projets c'est ça le
rugby municipalité en panique facilité
pour projet de se couvrir le coût
l'exigera disait on est là pour
faciliter diriger les gens vers telle ou
telle aventure de faire des prêts les
accords l'accompagnement qu'il faut par
contre on peut suggérer aux en culture
rime aujourd'hui qui sont peut-être
passif par ce qui s'apparente croix se
diriger par l'opa problème de
chlordécone
il est conseillé de sortir tel monde
agricole
ça c'est possible et c'est ça le rôle
des municipalités nous ne pouvons pas
nous encourager la diversité relation la
grenade
nous leurs à la campagne nous ne pouvons
nous substituer aux chefs d'entreprises
mais j'étais lundi je leur dis là
franchement j'étais un meilleur devenir
me dire ça m'a plu
comme entreprise si je n'ai pas l'idée
je dois je vois ma compagne de secours
je la cherche un local
je vais je vais mettre mes pas sotte il
va m'accompagner chaussures 7,5 ghana
mais par contre il ne peut pas à ma
place
monter notre pays n'a jamais c'est pas
possible il devient employé m'a placé
par le maire n'est plus un c'est pas le
rôle et la mission de faciliter comme on
a dit la gouttière is il ya quelque
chose au bon moment qu'il faudra
développer c'est créer un complexe avoir
alimenté ça si on le faire au monde ils
vont adopter de production implantés
pour pouvoir enfin rentrer cet art
culture favorable merci bertrand pierre
louis votre voisin julien milthon
comment voit-il le développement
agricole sur cette terre gros mornais
tout d'abord avant de vous répondre à
votre question directement je veux dit
je veux dire de ce couturier monsieur
couturier vous venez juste de dire que
vous ne recevez pas mais mécontent du
vous recevez à chaque fois les
bordereaux de transmission ça c'est une
première réponse
deuxièmement parce que je veux vous dire
avant de planter un poteau avec le
semaine et un cabinet d'étude et edf qui
viennent faire des études pour savoir
aux plantes et le poteau d'accord
3 troisième cherchent qu à venir alors
est ce que vous pensez sincèrement que
les gouvernants qui nous écoute a fait
savoir qu'il faut il vraiment intéressés
merci routier en iran sur quoi il faut
lui répondre à un cabinet d'études si un
couteau qui a été planté sous un
manguier je ne sais pas bien que ce ya
qu une seule extension de réseau qui a
été fait au goût monde et que je n'ai
pas reçu seul le dossier c'est le réseau
qui a été fait à la doite de la parcelle
de monsieur gilbert gauthier qui nous a
coûté 6 mai le haut je n'ai jamais vous
souhaite aussi
donc si on manque d'éléments sous son
impulsion pour soi mangue et ça doit
être là maintenant je pense qu'on est
clair je n'ai jamais reçu votre dossier
monsieur couturier et c'est pas avoir
qui fait planter je ne peux jamais faute
au sol de l'accord 2 df ni l'accord de
10 même d'accord ça nous a coûté 6
millions votre action des réseaux vous
aurez pu payer
voilà je reviens sur la culture du
gourmand un but du goût monde
moi je ne te comme je dis je pense avant
de faire la queue je suis pas
agriculteur mais je pense qu'il faudrait
consulter les agriculteurs pour savoir
ce qu'ils veulent vraiment pour
développer la culture du beau monde
voilà mon prince assez d'accord d'abord
un autre dit une consultation et ceux
des professionnels
ils feront ensuite déterminer
emmanuel granier vous aviez dit lors de
l'interview que nous avions fait
récemment pour votre présentation de
candidatures que vous regrettiez que les
agriculteurs du gros-morne doivent aller
à sainte-marie écouler leurs produits
aux manade sainte marie oui oui je
reprends c'était c'est une sottise vous
adressiez à l'équipe sortante
non mais ça va normal que quelque part
ils sont un petit peu moi j'avais comme
comptable dans une commune agricole
qu'on n'est pas bon il ya un constat
aferiat n'ya pas d'église n'y a pas de
marché attend deux tantes bon mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour les candidats sont capables de dire
la même chose
donc moi je dis que pour une commune
agricole il n'est pas normal que nos
agriculteurs iphone nos produits aux
mana on pouvait déjà trouver le moyen de
faire même si c'est un marché de son
power de manière à ce qu'ils puissent
vendre parce que ce que me coucherai a
dit devant la mairie ces voies les gens
vendent à même le sol à même le sol
il ya des problèmes quand même d'hygiène
et des choses de ce genre donc ça c'est
la partie la partie où tout le monde
tout le monde peut le dire par contre
moi je pense qu'il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs et cette histoire de
chlordécone pousser les gens à faire
faire les fruits pour savoir quel
solitaire qui sont plus sympathiques les
autres il faut développer l'agriculture
bio gaumont et il faut à ce moment là
que les gens le certificat parce qu'en
plus le test il est gratuit
donc ils peuvent faire venir sur le
terrain les gens qui sont aptes à faire
ce genre de choses là de manière à voir
quels sont les terres qui sont les plus
touchés à partir de cet instant
lorsqu'on va faire une fois sur des
produits agricoles aux gones ils ont le
devoir l'obligation de montrer qu'ils
ont produit sur un terrain non chlore
déconner avec un certificat qui va être
développée délivré par ses instances la
concernant autour de la table
agriculture parce que là je voulais que
vous aurez l'occasion l'émission d'un
message que je veux dire on attend des
sujets passionnants je cherche pas de
sujet on a tendance à ouvrir le feu sur
l'actuelle majorité
mais le déficit du gourmand bromont
début 2008 il y avait une majorité avant
et monsieur bourgi ans qu'il a était
adjoint et il détient aussi il était
aussi au conseil général
vous venez surtout ils n'ont jamais
pensé pour ça je l'avais pas non mais un
jour je vous dis pourquoi monsieur
girard est jetable en partie de la
situation actuelle du groupe
bien sûr l'ancien maire monsieur josé
ferrer n'a pas assuré sa mandature la
comptabilité de sa mandature
il ne l'a pas fait et moi je dis que si
nous sommes conduits aux affaires nous
allons faire nous allons demander à ce
qu'il y ait un audit de fait un audit
financier
un audit administratif que les choses
soient claires qu'on sache qu'on pente
à tel point et ancien là pour critiquer
ou encore créer des problèmes
aujourd'hui manière granier toile a
entendu alors vous verrez non voulait
pas répondre et le temps de répondre
granier qui a dit non c'est gilbert
couturier entendre les uns des autres
vous n'auriez pas la fibre agricole vous
je crois que chacun a le doit
effectivement retourner candidats pour
ce fairway
il y donnait sa version au gaumont n'y a
pas eu il n'y a pas de marché il est
pareil deux manches et manche est cassée
depuis avant la nature de 2008 2008
l'équipe
monsieur vous jouez à braver la mer
monsieur couturier mais pourquoi vous
dites l'équipe de monsieur roger partie
de l'équipe donné des consignes mais
c'est curieux ça on peut compter
10h10 très bas attendez attendez c'est
pas changé et qu'elle ait changé de
genre le respect de l'un et de l'autre
c'est ce que j'étais venu chercher
quelques ce s'exprime oui je n'étais pas
je n'interviens pas je crois que c'est
le respect de l'autre parce qu'il faut
intervenir à chaque fois je les odom ce
qui leur va maintenant sauf qu'on n'est
pas un conseil municipal on est en radio
et c'est que cette raison effectivement
on sait que vous êtes au départ puis
tous les ans on a dit tout le monde
n'est pas élu au conseil se sont donc
voilà les comptes avait changé dans le
respect de la loi l'équipe dont l'équipe
dont faisait partie monsieur vous
obtenez que monsieur le journaliste se
prend sur mon temps de parole déduire
poursuivent et les messieurs alors
j'explique le marché qui était à côté du
cimetière qui lie cosy alors je veux pas
la voir restaurer c'est ça il y avait
écrasé il ya une démarche de qualité il
était quoi j'étais jolie marge qui est
une question quand je vois politique
attendait des choix politiques de
l'équipe qui était l'adjoint réponse que
nous avons donnée à de l'équipe
alors je vous ont pas pourquoi le marché
a été écrasé je vous demande pourquoi
vous n'avez pas restaurée durant votre
mandature là qui s'achève alors dites
nous pourquoi les raisons qui ont faim
comme était d'aller au bout l'équipe
avons-nous 2008 va faire sur place
marrant des kiosques et qu'il voulait
crier comme marchés agricoles quand on
voit les conséquences parfois des des
armes des trucs qu'on a trouvé des
choses qui sont là à quel moment pouvait
louer pour le nhs exposants qui puisse
mettre ces produits là dedans comment la
ville soit écrit du credib la ville a
fait ce qui était nécessaire
d'abord pour vision au monde a travaillé
avec les propositions d'agriculteurs
mais aussi d'administrer pour occuper la
place mixed by ait eu au moment où on le
faisait nous avons tenu plusieurs
réunions avec des gens quittent les
exposants près de là où tu me la culture
mais aussi des marchands des
consommateurs qui nous ont dit quand tu
mets les manches et à mr dsk ou en bus
pour nous emmener
du coup il fait tout pour battre c'est
quand c'est pour cela que l'école mixte
aussi qui a été délocalisée et qui
aujourd'hui l'école
la place étant libre il y un projet déjà
voté en conseil municipal et qualité
d'élu qui sont là connaissent 420
millions ou 168 le haut que la 7e a
donné alors il fait a résumé gilbert
couturier sens il faudrait fermer 10 mai
les eaux de rue mais parce qu'on est
obligé de vous interrompre et que ce
marché l'appel d'offres lancé pour
pouvoir faire le marché sera devant à
l'école mixte c'est donc permettez on ne
sort pas un projet de claquement de
doigts il y en a qui sont semble dire à
la population comme eh oui non voix
d'accompagnement et des réunions qui ont
tous entendu avec les agriculteurs pour
le désenclavement lapidation pas d'à
coups à la situation
donc je nous avons fait des démarches
pour ma culture merci et le plein la
gueule tout l'été et exprimé sur l'un
des canaux cole est temps que le monde
s'est exprimé chez joly on va choisir
des noms va changer de thème vous
souhaitiez répondre sur
louis pour le monde faisait bien partie
de l'équipe je crois oui monsieur
monsieur je vais sur un oui oui un jour
j'étais fier général en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire non de l'oua
mise et de joueurs et qu'est ce que vous
avez foutu pendant fait c'est nous deux
on met un peu de tenue et voire même de
retenue respecte la fonction la fonction
que tu emploies répondu non non j'ai
tout de même je suis tunisien souvenirs
nature que le marché a été écrasé non
non non je ne joue dans une question
nous une question du tour le manche a
été détruit en 2000 et nous avons tous
combat love more 2000 opérateur roumain
de l'avant nous avons nous avons
critiqué la gestion ou en a on a des
tout le manche et ce en privant son
emplacement
d'accord on l'a fait et sécurité mais je
veux dire à monsieur gagné le début elle
n'est pas née en 2008
on dirait vont lui tout commence en 2008
bon bah pourquoi parce que vous y aurez
qu elle était encore inférieur ont mis à
rire à dominance parce que la gestion du
congrès c'est une continuité mais pour
moi c'est de renier tout commence en
peut-être qu'ils voulaient dire que vous
n'avez pas à redresser le d'arguments
qui ne m'a pas beaucoup alors ils
essayent de deux très bien je vous
propose donc de nous tourner vers
l'avenir
cap vers l'avenir on va parler donc de
l'aménagement équipements et
attractivité du smur du centre bourg un
nom c'est le deuxième thème de ce débat
de ce soir
le glaucome on l'a dit c'est une commune
rurale avec des atouts mais on a entendu
un qui a du mal qui ont du mal à émerger
alors comment faire réveiller les atouts
gâteau de cette ville
c'est le deuxième thème donc je les dis
qu'elles sont messieurs vos priorités en
la matière comment redonner de l'éclat à
votre ville en matière d'aménagement et
d'équipement du territoire monsieur marc
calixte oui oui mais voilà pendant mon
projet et mon programme n'est point
d'appui j'ai su tout l'innovation
technologique ou e mail ou et
redynamiser le bourg oui habilité le
bourg avec tout ce qui y est on vient du
tout à l'heure l'agritourisme alors dans
la vitrine j'ai par exemple fait venir
repreneur concept y est c'est elle qui
va proposer aux gones est du bengale ou
avec des sauts kalou à lui à -50% pas
sur l'engouement est un territoire qui a
une faveur d'avoir à 50% le robert et
repoussant les verrues organisé par
exemple un bout sans messi entreprises
sont déjà installés au moins on sait pas
lui concept antilles et des sacs a lieu
et puis au bout on en a dix points de
vue quand on parle de réhabiliter la
ville du golan et réhabiliter le beau
alors comment faire
justement toujours avec concept anti
positionner des bungalows à 10 h 30 et
j'ai évité de faire peut-être toute
publicité aussi s'il vous plaît parce qu
il avait déjà cité deux fois donc on va
s'arrêter là merci exactement
mais voilà donc et puis je prends
l'exemple de l'énergie renouvelable le
développement durable dans les villes où
elles il ya des fonds par exemple un
pôle excellence rurale ça permet de
d'avoir des fonds et réhabilité et la
ville et les quartiers de la commune ont
parlé du centre bourg en particulier de
faire venir des investisseurs
réhabiliter le bois par attirer des
entrepreneurs pas sur la ville ne va pas
réhabiliter le beau mais en terme
d'aménagement du territoire et
d'équipements aussi d'équipements
d'équipements qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour rendre ce centre
bourg plus attirant plus agréable à
pratiquer plus la promesse circuler plus
facilement tu souhaites à venir des
commerçants réhabiliter le bout pour
permettre aux gens comme disait monsieur
pierre pierre lui la mairie pour
faciliter c'est un ennui facilite
l'installation et donne des informations
sur les financements par exemple ceux
qui existent mais la commune n'est pas
chef d'entreprise comme un chef
d'entreprise de s'installer
la commune ne peut pas impulser les
projets monsieur grenier pour entier en
matière d'aménagement du territoire
si c'est possible ça mais je crois que
c'est celle de pulse et des projets de
permettre aux gens de pouvoir faire
de développer leur activité oui je vous
ai parlé du tableau là le problème de
parking qui fait que les gens ne peuvent
pas s'arrêter au bout pour acheter un
pain monsieur pierre lui disais donc il
ya un doute qu'au sujet de ce jeu aussi
mais la priorité pour le groupe
le rassemblement s'est même pas le
rassemblement
le gourmand le nom de la liste est
longue au monde c'est le bien être des
habitants s'étaient pas mal d'eau 2020
je suis vu un logo avec manou 2000
venant rien logo et 50 en 2020 mais le
nom de la liste le gone j'ai le goût
monde donc ce qui nous importe en fait
c'est de donner aux gens la vie de
revenir au goût membres de ne pas partir
du beau monde donner la parole aux
habitants dans les quartiers faire des
commissions de quartier permettent aux
gens de décider de ce dont ils ont envie
voir avec eux une démocratie
participative pour permettre aux gens de
dire nous aurions souhaité avancer le
projet peut-être pas celui là
faisons ensemble alors c'est facile de
dire que nous n'avons pas de projet
c'est à dire que nous faisons notre
projet en fonction de ce que les
habitants dans les différents quartiers
où nous passons avec des gens qui nous
reçoit volontiers chez eux dans des
réunions véranda qu'on puisse parler
avec eux y puisse développer des idées
et nous permettre compte que je vous
parle c'est pas très nouveau c'est ce
qu'on appelle la démocratie
participative
mais j'ai jamais dis que j'ai d'accord
j'ai fait ça c'est que vous voulez
appliquer c'est la méthode que nous
appliquons nous voulons que les gones
est puisse prendre la direction des
affaires parvenir leurs implants et
poser des choses mais construire avec
eux c'est ça qui importe en fait que des
gens aient envie parce qu'ils ont
participé bertrand pierre louis oui je
vois que il
fixer des objectifs donc il faut
effectivement créer des espaces créés
des espaces de liens du lien social où
il ya eu la créativité un marwijk le
marché en place ça c'est important c'est
l'une des priorités remise en marche en
place roy dynamiser les places publiques
parce qu'il n'a presque plus au monde ça
a été réduite à peau de chagrin devant
la mairie
on a un espace marché qui n'est pas un
espace marché que tout l'espace utilisé
pour bien autre chose face favoriser la
pratique du sport
c'est possible dans la bourse a c'est
possible créer un parcours santé dans la
bourse a c'est possible personne n'y ai
jamais pensé
nous on a le projet le faire et ensuite
créer un événement phare au monde
je prends un exemple prêcheur à ce qu'on
appelle une journée bouge ton qu il
vienne nous gave automobile comment le
ghanéen il faut on avait par le passé
une journée au moment qui était le lundi
de pentecôte que le président
association aujourd'hui thierry meyssan
qui ne vous connaît que je vois
aujourd'hui était organisée chaque année
cette journée outre la marty se
rassembler autour de la région joue le
grand pique nique géant
ça a disparu donc il faut refaire ça
venir il y avait une course pédestre qui
sortait de deux choux pour arriver au
gros monde ça a disparu au dessus du
temps de mon père est simple le
critérium des quartiers ça a disparu
dont il faudra faire remettre des
activités qui font venir du monde
on a eu de la chance cette année j'étais
sponsor du manifestations notamment un
tournoi de tennis open xi for women
j'ai vu des gens de toute la martinique
venir donc mais ce serait dommage qu'on
puisse pas trouver une journée émotive
ce serait ça trouver une journée un
élément déclencheur qui ferait que au
roman je sais par une libre de quoi
donner des migraines à ce qu'il était au
bilan du découpage et ça fonctionne on
peut faire quelque chose comme ça il
faut absolument que l'ogm roi donne goût
aux habitants de la martinique de
revenir vers eux pour dire comme tu
disais ma notoriété avant que les
pistaches l'édition b ça c'est possible
mais ça c'est sa loi est impulsée par la
municipalité paul cros serait mettre
l'activité au sein de la commune pour
faire renaître toute l'attractivité je
détournais tout est possible quand il
est possible de faire quand on veut tout
est possible il faut savoir me déplacer
un truc tu peux vous dire j'ai vécu en
guadeloupe qui s'appelait un commune qui
s'appelait vieux habitants eh ben j'ai
vu la municipalité en matière de maisons
insalubres
la mad qu'ils ont fait renault vais
accompagner les gens pourront à nouveau
leurs maisons européennes les façades
des maisons le remettre en état
mais c'est peut-être à une époque où les
moyens n'étaient pas les mêmes mais les
modalités avaient peut-être beaucoup
plus de moi il m'appelle mais toujours
toujours toujours toujours toujours
est-il on voit que le bout du bout monde
il faut faire
j'ai mon petit fils quelques temps avec
moi était obligé de dessin la trinité au
le faire s'épanouir dans un petit jardin
public
y'a rien aux gones pour serait cet hiver
d'un public
et qu'est ce que voulait dire la commune
est devenue plus d'un moins agréable à
vivre non moins les mots jolie moi je le
sais pas s'il fait moins bien vivre
augmente les olo vous il faut beaucoup
moins exactement c'est pour ça que la
population a beaucoup diminué
et alors qu on a construit des maisons
sociales augmentent de l'an dernier et
les gens les jeunes ne se sent pas bien
beau monde puisque il ya